das war übrigens noch so drin in meinen
30 bestellten Amazon secret Packs die
sozusagen einfach unzustellbare Pakete
sind Lichtstreifen von Hagemann green
Systems aha ja okay LED Flut light
lights instructions kein Stecker dabei
aber ich würde erstmal sagen das schaue
ich jetzt mal nach wie teuer das ist
scheiße 21.99 ihr müsst immer denken ich
habe 10 € pro Paket bezahlt Pen Mount
paar Schrauben für 10 €, ja perfekt die
haben Meter das sieht doch schon mal
ganz gut aus wir hoffen jetzt einfach
mal dass diese pH-Meter viel Geld kosten
dieses Gerät kostet tatsächlich 50 € 43
was ist das denn Tablet ne ist das ist
ein Tablet oder Navi und mir Alex wie
ach geil mein Highlight ist allerdings
dieser Hula Hoop Reifen naja kostet aber
auch nur so 30 € und am Strich muss es
leider sagen dass es sich für mich
erstmal nicht gelohnt hat